Один клік - і час паркування стартував. Завершується теж в один клік.
Так швидко і комфортно завдяки мобільному застосунку "Київ цифровий" можна оплатити паркування на будь-якій комунальній парковці столиці.
Утім, більш популярною залишається інша "опція" - незаконна.
За підрахунками аналітиків "Офісу трансформації", за парковку в Києві сплачує лише півтора відсотка водіїв.
Решта - або займають паркомісця безкоштовно, або ж платять ось таким чоловічкам в жилетах.
- Мені на пів години.
- 20 гривень.
При цьому у столичній мерії вже багато років обіцяють побороти паркувальний безлад:
розігнати нелегальних паркувальників, налагодити зрозумілу систему оплати за паркування
та систему штрафування тих, хто паркується не за правилами.
Одна з останніх обіцянок КМДА - запуск автоматизованої системи контролю за паркуванням.
Розмови про неї точаться ще з 2018 року, коли був ухвалений  закон про паркування.
Ця програма нарешті дозволила б значно швидше й ефективніше працювати інспекторам-паркувальникам.
В інспектора є окремо планшет і окремо інспекторське місце роботи,
яке забезпечує доступ до реєстру і перевіряє, чи сплачено, чи не сплачено.
Крім цього інспектор може перевіряти на порушення і складати протокол на порушення правил
не тільки за несплату, але і за неправильне паркування.
Адже нині, аби визначити серед усіх припаркованих авто порушника,
інспекторам з паркування треба відправити дані про автомобіль в офіс, де їх звіряють.
Така перевірка інформації займає не менше 30 хвилин для одного авто.
На це в інспекторів, схоже, немає ані часу, ані бажання.
За даними Департаменту транспортної інфраструктури, торік у такий спосіб у Києві виписали лише 61 штраф на суму 11 тисяч гривень.
Тобто за тиждень штрафували в середньому одного водія.
У тестовому режимі автоматизована система контролю паркування мала б запрацювати ще у лютому,
принаймні так обіцяв відповідальний за її створення Петро Оленич на одному з брифінгів взимку.
На наступному тижні буде пресконференція, присвячена цьому питанню. Окремо будуть названі терміни впровадження,
період тестової експлуатації, період запуску - все це буде зроблено в найближчі місяці, все буде працювати.
Втім, на вулиці вже майже цвітуть каштани, а система так і не працює.
Про причини такої відстрочки відповідальні чиновники прямо не говорять.
Кажуть, що сервіс надто складний і вимагає узгодження з багатьма міськими реєстрами.
З іншого боку і взялись за нього теж не вчора.
З 2015 року відповідальними за усі цифрові сервіси міста була ініціатива  Kyiv Smart City.
Однак цей добре відомий киянам додаток з ініціативи КМДА на початку року припинив свою роботу.
Серед офіційних причин - те, що додаток, а, отже, весь програмний код та логотип належать громадській організації, а не місту.
Хоча розробники Kyiv Smart City наголошували - конфіденційна інформація належала місту.
Зрештою відповідне рішення мерії Києва коштувало киянам купу часу і мільйони гривень.
Тепер же над системою працюють розробники комунального підприємства "Головний інформаційно-обчислювальний центр".
І схоже, відстрочка запуску програми вказує на те, що з завданням вони наразі не справляються.
Цікаво, що в Дніпрі схожа система перевірки оплати за парковку діє вже другий рік і запустили її за пів року.
Костянтин Усов віднедавна відповідає за впровадження паркувальної реформи в Києві і запевняє,
що діє лише в інтересах киян, а про дії попередників не в курсі.
Все дуже просто, і я вам чітко і прямо кажу як відповідальна за це людина, що у міста є політична воля
на створення цивілізованих умов для паркування , на створення таких умов швидко, ефективно,
щоб це бачили всі кияни.
Що відбувалось у попередні періоди мені важко коментувати.
В деталях розумію, що відбувається в місті, яке зазначили Ви.
Ви ж маєте розуміти, що там програмний комплекс не належить місту,
а належить приватній компанії, яка контролює всі дані і процеси.
І можливо, не всі кияни погодилися б з таким підходом, щоб він був застосований в нас.
Максим Бахматов, засновник ГО "Офіс трансформації", бачить вирішення проблеми нелегальної парковки
саме у залученні приватного сектору.
Що б я робив, я б робив систему паркування з використанням приватного інвестора,
за принципом PPP - Public Private Partnership, щоб залучити гроші і не витрачати комунальні.
А з партнером ділити гроші, які будуть збиратись.
Питання в тому, що комунальні підприємства - дуже неефективні менеджери.
Їхня діяльність не пов'язана з ефективністю, а з тим,
щоб отримати доступ до комунальних грошей і зав'язати себе у потенційно корупційних схемах.
А коли у тебе акцент не на ефективне використання, а на корупцію,
то що б не будував, на виході буде щось неефективне, некрасиве і те, що не буде працювати.
Будучи радником Кличка, Бахматов у 2020-му запустив у місті роботу евакуаторів.
За понад рік роботи разом з інспекторами вони евакуювали 76 тисяч неправильно припаркованих автівок -
це близько 200 автівок в день.
Штрафи, які сплачують водії, йдуть переважно приватним компаніям, які здійснюють послугу евакуації.
Евакуюють переважно автівки, які припарковані із суворими порушеннями ПДР.
Таких у столиці багато. Ось, приміром, біля Палацу спорту водій зайняв проїжджу смугу.
Це при тому, що за новими удосконаленими правилами паркування, які уряд ухвалив з початку квітня,
тепер паркувати авто заборонено й на тротуарах.
Чи не найбільшу проблему в сфері паркування нині створюють водії,
які паркуються так би мовити "на 5 хвилин" і не платять за послугу.
- Відпочити зупинився на 15-20 хвилин.
- Ось пішки хвилина і парковка.
- Платна?
- 20 гривень/година.
- Йдіть і паркуйтеся.
- А ви не готові плати?
- Ні.
- Чому?
- За що ?
- За паркуавння.
- За паркуавння? Воно там обладнане, зроблене? Хтось інвестував туди кошти?
Це все навколо моє, це було зроблено до них. Чому вони мають цим користуватися?
Таке ставлення автомобілістів не дивує спеціаліста з транспортного планування Дмитра Беспалова.
Адже, як вказує експерт, за останні роки боротьби з порушниками парковок не було проведено жодної інформаційної кампанії
і не роз’яснено водіям, що паркування, і особливо в в центрі міста - це розкіш, за яку треба  платити.
Евакуації та боротьба з порушеннями правил паркування точкова і так і залишається точковою.
Шанс отримати в Києві евакуацію невеликий.
Паркомісць більше не з'явилося. Ми не використали зміни в ДБН.
Можна було зробити смуги вужчими, можна було намалювати додаткові паркомісця - ми цього не зробили.
Водночас за мерства Кличка коштом киян було встановлено
чимало так би мовити "інноваційних" паркоматів, які нині не працюють або взагалі демонтовані.
Експерт радить мерії припинити точкові експерименти з паркуванням.
Кількість автівок у столиці щороку збільшується на 50 тисяч.
У разі відсутності стратегічних рішень ситуація з кожним роком буде лише погіршуватись.